[Music]
how many you want to do yes I've got
this
the Canon R50 replacing the iconic M50
was just an ounce alongside the R8 now
we have a video for the R8 as well so
you can check that out after this and I
was playing with the R50 most of the
time Zachy was playing with the R8 when
we had a chance to video and photograph
this Chef making us a fantastic lunch of
course Canon um set this up so we had
some content to shoot because we could
not take the cameras out into the wild
as of yet because of uh ndas and all
that great stuff but we got some
Hands-On time with these people
production cameras and I gotta tell you
the R50 is very impressive now to me it
looks like Canon is competing against
the Sony zve10 interchangeable aps-c uh
camera system 24.2 megapixel sensor on
this you've got the Dual pixel CMOS af2
Auto focusing tracking system which
we're seeing in a lot of the newer
cameras coming from Canon it's great it
looks fantastic it sticks on your eye
Like Glue no issues at all with that but
there's a lot of new bells and whistles
and some AI put into this camera that
makes it a lot more easier to use for
Content creators and for photographers
out there case in point you've got some
creative modes for photography if you
want to take a photo it will take three
or four different versions with
different filters on side of it so it's
kind of like having this go inside your
camera system now you can't control the
filters per se but they just kind of
shoot them out as they go and some of
the filters look okay I mean they're not
wow but they're kind of cool and they
kind of you know simplifies the editing
process if you just want to get a photo
out there to share on Instagram Facebook
or Tick Tock what have you now what's
interesting about this as well is that
it will also detect when you have back
Glide against yourself and it will
adjust the exposure and the aperture et
cetera et cetera when you have it set to
that mode which is great for a lot of
people that don't know how a camera
actually works but want to get really
good exposure no matter what lighting
situation they're in this camera has you
covered also it has a feature that we
did see on the zve E10 and the zv1 it's
like the product showcase we saw from
Sony or if you're uh you know talking
about a product let's say I'm talking
about this phone right here and I put it
to camera it will actually rack to the
product I pull it away it goes back to
my base so that's something that they
have inside of this as well but what I
did is I did some vlogging with this
because Canon is touting this as a great
vlogging camera so we tried it with some
of the new lenses out that Canon
released now the newest one the 55 210
was a little bit too long to Vlog on
aps-c at 55 210 it's not gonna work
you're going to see my eyelash and
that's about it but I did try some other
lenses out there so go check out some
footage I did of myself and Zaki
vlogging with this and I'll come back
with my final thoughts this video is
brought to you by MSI meet the summit
e16 flip
flip of Jen into
7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and a
16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the Sony e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime all right here we
are R50 vlogging style using the 24 1.8
there is a heavy crop on this because
I've got is enable but you could
actually press a button onto the display
and then that will take away is then it
will go full sensor with so you have an
option to go both on this with 24 I'm a
little bit close
there's Zachy right there
filming the chef as you can see right
there is tracking beautifully
back to me looks great let me go to uh
all right now I'm full with the sensor
now I had to actually turn off recording
to do that I can't just do that when the
camera is recording
all right let's go around here
all the way now there's the chef
yeah go for it are you doing your
assault Bay thing no
three two
that's Crouton Bay not Salt Bay
there you go there we go that's it don't
worry about it don't worry about it
three
yeah not bad let's get the colors on
this look great this is fantastic
truffle oil truffle oil okay
okay
we got four guys see the full ball right
here we're having that
same focus on gin over there and then
went to me yeah so detects the face
hello
[Music]
no no it's okay I'm trying this out so
we're doing this uh product close up
here so Ken's got this sitting in the
R50 where it actually detect the product
before go out for that matter and it
goes back to me right Zacky yeah so we
should link it we should think it think
it sink it and sync it sync it
was good for guap oh wow look at that
naturally caramine
look at that you guys like foie gras hey
if you take a look together
look at that
look at that beautiful bokeh 24 1.8 look
at that
actually this is really nice
you have to do the influence something
like
um
so you have to go into the camera system
and you have to actually set this up the
way you want to do it so it's kind of in
the menu I don't know if you can assign
it to a custom button on the camera that
would be really cool just to press and
go but all these things you have to do
uh before you record you cannot do it
while you're in the midst of recording
so let's say I'm in the is mode I can't
go right to product video mode I gotta
stop and I gotta set that up so and this
lens is awesome I like this lens this is
a great deal this 24 one point is a very
good lens really good lens sharp good
exposure how you like it
truffle mushroom soup
[Music]
look at that
we're eating all this look what Chef's
eating
night right you just I do a cup of
making yep rice and fried eggs
food that touches the heart of course we
make very good food I mean we know that
still like the food that touches the
heart on daily basis
but your food touched my heart good now
I have to kiss you later
okay now I'm trying out the all-new 24
to 50 RF lens it's at 4.5 to 6.3 as is
inside of it now this is one of the new
lenses here for the arm out good budget
friendly zoom lens exactly taking a
photo of me right now with the camera
we're shot first shot and it's
lightweight too which is nice so if you
want to do some vlogging with this you
can
and yeah it was good right honestly
speaking with the um
check out the the video on the re yeah
good with the light weakness light
weakness lightweight lightweight it's a
word yes lightweight is a word
lightweight is a word right it's great
for handheld like zero so if you ever
want to do those creative style I can't
help you okay the is yes it's really
good
[Music]
la la
all right as we saw it's a fun camera to
use it's lightweight it really performs
well the auto focusing system inside
this camera does not miss at all I
really enjoyed it as a matter of fact
this would be a nice little camera to
take with you on a holiday or if you're
just going to do some vlogging and you
want to do something for YouTube or
Instagram or Tick Tock this is a good
camera and it depends on the lenses you
get you're gonna get some really good
image quality now some of these budget
lenses have a higher aperture number so
that means you're gonna you're gonna
face some situations in lower light you
know lighting scenarios but if you have
a decent lens on this you're gonna get
some really good images out of this for
video and for photo as well I gotta hand
it to Canon I like what they did with
this release of the R8 and the R50
bringing these cameras to a much more
mass Market that can't afford the
flagship camera as the five six seven
eight thousand dollar cameras to Market
which are just you know cameras are
getting more expensive and I understand
it the technology is getting better the
lenses et cetera et cetera et cetera but
I mean it's nice to have something like
this and the R50 is going to be a great
camera for a lot of people out there and
you know it was kind of sad the other
day I was at a camera shop here in
Singapore and I saw this couple buying
M50 and I'm thinking to myself I just
play with the R50 oh guys I wish I could
say something but I couldn't sign my
life away but maybe they'll return it
and get the R50 instead maybe there's an
exchange policy who knows but uh this
camera a lot of people are gonna like it
comes in white it comes in Black I
prefer the black but some people might
like the white to each their choice
anyway those are my thoughts on the
Canon R50 and we will do a full review
when we get a production unit in hand
but this is a pre-production so I can
just talk about the Top Line specs and
how it performed but I gotta say it
works really well and if you like this
video check out more of our reviews
right here foreign
[Music]